c'est le chiffre de la journée 4
millions et demi de personnes le nombre
d'ukrainien privé ces dernières heures
d'électricité la faute vous le savez aux
innombrables bombardements russes une
terreur énergétique ce sont les mots ces
dernières heures du Président zellenki
on retrouve notre correspondant Ukraine
Gulliver crack bonjour Gulliver la
situation devient donc critique pour des
millions du crayon les habitants de Kiev
ne sont bien sûr pas épargnés
oui la capitale est l'un des endroits
les plus touchés en réalité ce matin il
y avait 450
000 foyers dans Kiev qui était privé est
électricité c'est vous considérez que la
population totale de la ville est
d'environ 4 millions cela fait un assez
bon pourcentage des qui est bon qui
était sans électricité ce matin il
s'agit de coupure programmée plus ou
moins programmée selon les autorités
pour faciliter les réparations mais
visiblement les compagnies d'électricité
ne sont pas vraiment capables d'adhérer
à leur programme ils avaient promis au
début de
lancement de cette stratégie si vous
voulez que les coupures ne seraient pas
d'une durée de plus de 4 heures
maintenant c'est souvent beaucoup plus
que 4 heures j'ai des connaissances qui
ont reçu le message ce matin comme quoi
il n'aurait pas d'électricité entre 7h
du matin et 11h du soir ce n'est pas le
cas pour tous les quartiers de Kiev dans
mon appartement j'ai de l'électricité
par exemple mais beaucoup d'endroits
semblent souffrir de plus en plus
alors que ces réparations continuent
mais peut-être comment se rencontrer des
difficultés à cause notamment de la
pénurie de près de pièces quand la
Russie a commencé à systématiquement
attaquer les infrastructeurs électriques
l'Ukraine les compagnies d'électricité
avait un certain nombre de pièces pour
remplacer ce qui avait été endommagé
rapidement maintenant et il se disent
que leur stock commence à s'épuiser et
justement c'est frappe russe Gulliver
est-ce qu'elle se poursuivent encore
aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas eu ces derniers jours de
frapper russe sur les infrastructures
électriques dans le sens de frappe de
longue distance missiles de croisière ou
utilisation de drones du moins pas sur
les endroits loin de la ligne de front
mais il y a quelques endroits au Ukraine
qui ne sont pas prêts des lignes de fond
ni dans le sud ni dans l'Est qui souffre
presque quotidiennement de Fabrice pour
une raison ou une autre c'est notamment
le cas de le district de nico-paul dans
la région de ni pro petrovsk juste sur
le fleuve là en face de la centrale
nucléaire de zapporisa qui est une sorte
de plate d'armes pour les Russes encore
cette nuit nicopole a été touché même si
les systèmes de défense ont été aériens
Ukrainiens disent avoir abattu 8 sur 8
des drones iraniens said qui avait été
utilisé mais en plus c'était trop il y
avait aussi des requêtes et aussi la
raison de soumis dans le nord-est de
l'Ukraine est presque quotidiennement la
cible de frappe à travers la matière
depuis la Russie voisine merci beaucoup
Gulliver pour toutes ces informations on
vous retrouve bien sûr